look how it hits the thing ew
what like here please
huge fan of subway it's like a good
cheap
go-to that's not super super unhealthy
love me the five dollar foot long
i love bread i'm like oprah and i like
that jalapeno cheddar bread
there's something about that special
bread smell when you walk
into a subway and you smell that fresh
bread stuff like
so many options yeah
really good mm-hmm it tastes like pizza
it's just like pizza i like it yeah i
actually don't like oh it's not bad
i do love those peppers though it's a
little dry
the chicken this bread is really good
though it's almost better than a piece
of pizza i don't know
someone had a bunch of random in their
fridge and tried to make a sandwich
and it's not good
[Music]
it just looks like a soggy salad and
soggy
bread oh my god i hate spicy food
so much get us a milk it's spicy
and it's sweet and it's soggy it's a
triple threat of badness
maybe just like get the sauce and
vegetables and leave the bread out make
a salad
yeah make it toastier
why would you name a sandwich the heart
attack i have high cholesterol
oh it's tuna and bacon
oh my god this is really [ __ ] good
it's better than the others i don't even
know
if that's lettuce girl don't look at it
because you know what they say
never judge a book by its cover
this
this is incredible it's so good
i can't stop eating it yeah this is
definitely not bad
it is actually it looks really good this
is not
subway eat fresh though this is subway
eat fat
i'm just not smart enough when i'm drunk
to make these amazing combinations of
foods
i think i'm just going to stick to what
i know when it comes to subway i don't
we know what's in it
don't need that soggy salad the supreme
pizza sub was really good that needs to
be sold as a sub if they don't already
have it yeah that's it
i'm done